please bear with me while I read out a
standard uh announcement
please there are no planned fire drills
so if the fire alarm goes off please
leave the building in an orderly fashion
through the nearest fire exit please use
either the front exit through the main
doors of the hall or the fire exit in
the store room a jang to the stage
that's to my
left the fire assembly point is the
island in front of the main entrance to
the
building please do not delay your
evacuation to collect any belongings and
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by the
council
staff please note that this meeting will
be live
streamed please switch off mobile phones
or turn them to
silent please note that the toilet and
handwashing facilities are in the foer
area particular notice now members of
the public you are entitled to film or
take photographs during this meeting but
can I please emphasize to you that this
should only be done without disruption
to the meeting and can only be done from
a designated area in the public
seating can I therefore please
ask anybody who intends to take
photographs or film this evening please
put your hand clearly in the
air that's
no
Show members a reminder especially for
me your voice will only be captured on
the live stream when your microphone is
switched
on please remember to switch on your
microphone when you are invited to speak
and switch off again when not speaking
to avoid feedback
noise voting will be done on a show of
hands in line with the
Constitution I will ask for a show of
hands for and then against
recommendations and will also ask for a
show of hands for those wishing to
abstain from
voting I have two apologies for Action
uh for absence or which is item one on
the agenda councelor Ian Ward apologized
has not been able to attend counselor
Dave sparin is substituting for
him also apologize on behalf of Officer
Lee Nicholson he is the new interim
director of
place but he's double booked tonight and
he was previously booked for a
development meeting over in Brentwood
they've got a committee meeting tonight
he sends his
apologies non-members attending I can
see councelor marott from holbridge over
there I think that's the only
one okay we move on to item three the
minutes of meeting held on the 17th of
October
2023 has anybody got any comments or can
I assume that the minutes are
noted
noted they'll be
noted I now invite any members if they
have any Declarations of
Interest councilor stept uh as a member
of ESS County Council and member of
Barling Magna Parish
Council thank you councilor
EES as uh chairman of the development
committee at rodford District Council
thank you Council sparing member of Ry
Town Council chairman thank you
before we move on uh I'd like to know
make another
introduction so people can put a face to
her name to my right here is Jonathan
quilter he's joining us um in his role
as corporate plan strategic planning
manager effectively he's covering the
loss of uh Dan goodin who left us
Goodman
sorry so welcome aboard everybody's got
their name up so you can s start to
familiarize yourself with the
faces okay item five the first item of
real business is local development
scheme 2024
26 Jonathan quilter will himself present
this
report and then we'll talk about it
group you
wish thank you chair and thank you
members um so yes as the report sets out
um before you um we've got an updated
local development scheme which is the uh
timetable that sets out how we're going
to prepare the uh local development plan
um so we have um in terms of the
recommendations uh we have um
recommendation one that the planning
policy committee notes the proposed
program plan as set out in appendix B
which provides obviously more the
background detail to that timetable
and then recommendation recommendation
two that the policy committee recommends
to full Council that the development
scheme 2024 26 as attached to pendix a
be adopted and published on the
council's website so in terms of the
background of the report um as set out
we have um obviously a requirement to
have an upto-date local development
scheme um as as set out in
legislation um the national plan policy
framework and the associated practice
guidance advises that we keep that as up
to date as possible um generally
speaking as a minimum annually or as and
when needed um in respect of the
development scheme for uh rushford's
local plan uh we have obviously recently
um been progressing a number of
documents um and we've been working on a
number of different evidence uh
documents that have come to this
committee previously um as with any
local plan there are always going to be
potential delays and that have occurred
as a result of that so we have obviously
focused in on there on the um the
transport assessment work and the
infrastructure delivery plan work um
which has been making progress but has
not progressed as quickly as we
anticipated originally um so the updated
development schemes now sets out that we
would expect a regulation 18
consultation to take place in quarter
three of this year uh and obviously the
subsequent um events such as the
pre-submission and submission so forth
will take place following that um the
the overarching point around the
government's intention uh to bring in
obviously new plan making regime uh
that's still to be formally published
but obviously it's still imminent in
respect of um the the summer 2025
deadline that's referred to in 3.6
paragraph 3.6 and that obviously looks
at the um that's around June I think
they're looking potentially to bring
that in so if a plan is not submitted by
that point then um it'll be expected
that the plan would have to be prepared
in line with that new guidance um but
obviously as we've set out here we're
Our intention at this stag is still to
try to proceed and submit before that
deadline
um I think that gives a good summary
there but if there's any questions I'm
happy to take those
chair thank you any questions
members Council thank you chairman um on
page 54 5.5 you have
highlighted relevant risks would you
care to elaborate on that a little bit I
mean is it resources that you're
concerned about or is it other factors
that uh may come into
play thank you chair um yes so in terms
of of risks I think we always have to
look at what are the potential risk and
as you say there are um implications
potentially on on resource um as we've
just indicated at the beginning
obviously I've come into this post um as
soon as obviously Daniel Goodman has
left so there is a continuation there um
and uh the ability to obviously going
forward there is the the program to look
at a you know wider resourcing across
both councils and that that can be drawn
upon potentially as well um when it
comes to um the obviously there are a
number of documents that are being
progressed by our consultants and we
obviously keeping a close eye on those
as well when it comes to progression of
that work um as you as You' expect um in
terms of other risks I think the
external risks or potential other
changes may or may not happen when it
comes to government uh change that's not
new really that's always a potential um
so we have to keep a close eye on that
as and when that does potentially get
published um obviously with the uh
updates to the mppf we need to obviously
keep an eye on that how that potentially
impacts on our program um but as things
stand today obviously we've set that out
as we expect what we can progress with
what's before us really so I think in
terms of um those risks that we put
there they're they're not abnormal but
they're obviously something that we need
to keep under review and keep under
check really so obviously with the the
requirement to keep this development
scheme up to date as possible but at the
same time Drive forwards with this plan
and make sure it can be produced in a
timely
manner can I just come back CH is there
any financial implications that uh
because of the resourcing that we need
that we we might start having to look
into other areas of Finance to to make
sure that we get the consultation people
in or whatever we need to to keep the
thing on track we didn't we we all know
we we got to keep on track with this
when you know that is critical so uh you
know just a simple question do we
anticipate any any areas where we might
have to start looking for other
alternative funding or ring other
areas um thank you chair so in terms at
this stage I don't think necessarily
have got a specific answer about how it
could potentially affect other Finance
obviously that may will be a wider
strategic decision for the corporate
leadership team um but in terms of what
we've got set out in the budget at the
moment there is the the budget obviously
has agreed that can be drawn down upon
to to to pay towards the work that's
being done um all of the um the key
evidence documents are underway so they
have obviously their own contracts and
things that are being Advanced so I
think it's uh clearly there's always a
need again to keep a a check and review
on that but I think as it stands it's
currently I don't anticipate there's
there sort of expectation that that is
going to have to happen um and things
are able to progress as they need to
when it comes to the um the consultation
um obviously there's um set processes
that we need to go through but we've got
the systems there to be able to
undertake those uh and obviously within
the team we were able to sort of
progress that as as we need
to thanks chairman Foster yeah thanks
chairman I actually had the same
question there so I'd just like to
welcome Jonathan quilter to their team
thank you I've got some other questions
for later on in the report I'll hold
them till we move through if that's all
right this report yeah should I take
them now okay um there's on page 5
10 and
513 and
516 there's various comments to the uh
local uh neighborhood
plans the ones that are referenced in
the report quite
old um and it it says that parishes can
update them if they wish so my question
is really twofold is one are the
parishes aware that that is something
that they could be or would wish to be
working on and if so have they got the
resources to do
that yeah thank you chair yeah apologies
obviously for this catching up on on
that aspect but yeah I think in ter
clearly we can um if there hasn't been
communication recently we're happy to to
sort get in touch and understand where
they stand at the moment on that and um
yeah we want to make sure that they're
aware of our program uh in terms of
obiously alignment with that um in terms
of neighborhood plans generally there is
the need to them they're being developed
ideally they want to be done in parallel
um or soon after um so yeah certainly
we're happy to to look into that in
terms of the um the existing
arrangements and what what can be done
to continue that that
conversation okay thank
you Council step
to thank you chairman um couple of uh
point you mentioned in your presentation
about the traffic survey um can we have
an update on where we are within that
particular process uh and when we can
expect a report to come before this
committee uh because it's going to be a
very important part of what we need to
do taking forward um I'll let you answer
that one I've got another question after
that thank you chair um yes so we've
obviously got the overiew view in
appendix B which gives sort of an idea
generally where the um the reports are
heading so we've got the local transport
assessment um clearly that that work is
um not done in isolation we do need to
work closely with Essex highways um as a
highway Authority um we've got our own
Consultants who with the council's
appointed who are undertaking that work
on our behalf um so um that provides
sort bit more scrutiny from us um which
is helpful um but yeah in terms of the
outputs of that work um so we're looking
um in terms of that that draft work we
got some expecting something in sort of
the latter part of March this year
potentially um that that would be sort
of draft um information that be
available and I think in terms of
actually the the report itself it'll be
expected potentially towards the end of
April so I think obviously given the um
the uh elections and the pre-election
period it's going to be after that
election period that something could
come to committee I think that obviously
that that output would be at the
earliest available um but clearly
obviously the transport assessment work
as we know is complex but we want to
make sure it's properly scrutinized and
there's the uh information available for
members to be able to interrogate that
as best possible so we'll make sure
that's available at the right
time and the other question I had was
with regards to uh paragraph 3.11 on
page
512 uh a comment on the uh Community
infrastructure Levy um the council is
not actively pursuing this
uh can I ask
why yeah thank you chair um yeah so at
this time as I understand it at least I
may be incorrect that the the council
hasn't made a formal decision to to for
example not do it but obviously equally
hasn't decided to take it ahead yet so
based on my own personal experience I
think the way that we have to bring seal
forward it probably would would have to
be soon after the adoption of a plan
because really it does rely upon the
outputs and the finalized um plan and
evidence that supports that so for
example viability evidence and the
infrastructure delivery plan which would
obviously provide the um the evidence to
support Community infrastructure Levy um
so I don't don't I wouldn't take it as
being ruled out I think it's just
obviously in terms of the the timing of
that it would obviously have to follow
in sequence after adoption of a local
plan um and that that could be done
relatively quickly um so as an example
in brenwood they have just recently
implemented sill uh and that came in um
just under well just over a year after
we adopted the plan there so it's kind
on that basis there is the ability to
bring that forward fairly quickly
following a plan so
you councilor Foster yeah thank you
chairman I forgot one I meant to ask um
on page
5.13 paragraph 4.3
4.4 uh the biodiversity net gain
requirement now I understand it was Da
by the government with the various
implementation dates the question is
um we're scheduled to have draft
consultation ready by Q3
2024 U but in the in the um report it
says the implementation dates are set
out between January and April 24 are we
are we missing the trick there or is how
I misreading
that okay thank you chair um yes so I
believe probably since this report was
published I think there's been a further
delay unfortunately on the government's
part with regards to some of that um
guidance being published I think it's
now going to be in probably February
time and that some of that is push
pushed out um when it comes to the SBD
um for the council um so I think that
that obviously can follow um clearly the
requirement will be there from
government when it comes to that
bringing port in place and but the SBD
itself will obviously provide that
further Clarity for the council but also
any other developers or things that come
forward to what we expect from them uh
when it comes to biodiversity net gain
clearly the minimum requirement will be
10% I know some authorities are looking
for 20% for example so I think there
there's clearly an appetite for that in
some places and I suspect it will be
here um but we need to have set that out
within that SPD um so I think yeah the I
yeah I appreciate the misalignment there
but I think it's probably also slightly
changed since then unfortunately but we
again we'll keep on top of that uh and
react accordingly um to make sure we've
got the right um guidance in
place okay thank you Council
Hoy yeah thank you
chairman um two questions one was caring
on from the
sill can you tell me
who or where the S decision is made
within the council is it on the
executive is it the lead member for
planning is it this
committee yeah thank you chair um I'll
be honest I don't know the answer to
that but I'm sure we can find out for
you if that was the case there may well
be a decision that needs to it needs to
be discussed about how that could be
decided yeah I think it would be useful
if we knew
yeah um the
second it's not a real question it's uh
on page 5.15 item
6.1 we've got a risk of
mitigation when I normally see a risk of
mitigation I
normally we we normally have a level of
risk of
of How likely something is to happen but
then I'd also expect a a risk of the
effect of that happening so you get the
red red Amber green and I think this on
6.1 would be much more useful if we had
that fully done rather than just half of
it done can that be redone and
circulated to memb so we can understand
that a bit more
clearly yeah thank you ch certainly we
can look into that if there's a need for
more clarification um happy to look into
that for
you Council
Rees following on from a couple of
members uh points earlier on on the uh
risk uh listing um one of the things on
the second item there is uh to
incorporate contingencies in the local
plan can you expl can you expand rather
on what those contingencies might be
please
thank you chair um I think probably in
simple terms it's probably um making
sure we got the appropriate time frames
associated with that so obviously not to
be unnecessarily long but I think being
realistic around some of the leading
times um but yeah I think that that is
probably the extent of that really
rather than if you more sort of
elaborate but yeah I think that that
effectively is the the continency of of
time um so to add that in the
appropriate way thank
you any more question
members your mic's
on okay thank you uh on that point then
um there are two
recommendations recommendation number
one that the planning policy committee
notes the proposed program plan set out
at appendix
B is that noted
gentlemen thank
you item
two that the planning policy committee
recommends to full Council that the
local development scheme 2024 to 26
attached as appendix a be adopted and
published on the council's
website we need to go to a vote on this
one has anybody uh want sorry do anybody
want to propose a motion on
this um sorry chair before you go
further with that with the appropriate
adjustments to um
6.1 as I we talked about just now so it
has a more fully rounded risk
register I think chair just in in terms
of process that can be dealt with
outside the recommendation because
that's just part of the report so I
think just stick with the actual
recommendation as it stands
chair okay thank you I'll propose uh
that the planning policy committee
recommends to full Council that the
local development scheme 202 4 26
attached as a pendic say be adopted and
published on the council website do I
have a second
please councilor e is second
in now we go to vote in the usual
format when you vote can you please
raise your hands and keep them up there
while the officers count thank
you first of
all
call for those to vote for the
motion unanimous thank
you I won't go through the against and
the abstain
it's
we move on to item
six which is a bit of a
giant report uh it's the employment land
study
2024 officer D Daniel kudler will
present this
report thank you thank you
chair um yes so as um chairman mentioned
I I'm presenting our employment land
study or El this evening um the
recommendation is that committee notes
this report as part of the evidence
space for the new local plan um this is
the bit of context this is the second
piece of um three bits of evidence
supporting the economy and employment
element of the new local plan uh at the
last Committee in October we presented
the first of these which is the economic
development needs assessment or Edna and
we expect the next committee will see us
presenting um a commercial property
market review to give a a commercial
Market view of of need um the El
provides a definitive position statement
on employment land study within the
district to meet future needs using both
quantitative and qualitative analysis um
reviews each of the district's existing
employment sites in turn considering
various attributes capacity and
constraints to determine how they might
contribute to supporting um a vibrant
and thriving local economy through the
timeline of the new plan um the Edna of
context modeled future possible demand
for different types of employment space
and considered whether our existing
Supply was sufficient to meet our
projected needs based on the number of
scenarios the takes this further and
considering some of the wider factors
that need to be considered and to come
up with a figure for how much new
employment land might be needed through
the plan period and ways of meeting this
um so the study itself um so the this
was done inhouse and the team looks at
35 different sites across the districts
um this included both existing allocated
employment sites established ones uh
sites which were newly designated under
the current core strategy um for example
the airport Business Park and sites
which were formerly employment sites
sites um sites which are not formally
allocated but which have a significant
employment role and finally sites being
promoted for consideration of future
employment allocations through the call
for sites process um if you refer to the
item six report Table one um this sets
out the sites surveyed by their
respective categories as well as the
approximate area in hectares of each
site there's also a map just below this
figure one and that shows how the
different sites are distributed around
the districts um for the purposes of the
study they've been grouped into one of
six clusters for EAS of
discussion um and that's all within the
fall report as well and the appendix uh
the team visit the team visited each one
of these sites assessing key aspects
such as access site quality amenities
occupancy any constraints and we gave
each site a score made recommendations
on few future actions for each including
web to protect and maintain it as it is
whe whether it needs further enhancement
um whether more serious intervention was
required if the site wasn't performing
as expected um also whether the site
should be considered for allocation or
protection in the plan if it didn't
already benefit from this uh so in terms
of going on to fightings um overall site
surveyed amounted a total of um 315
hectares although of this 183 hectares
was actually land currently either in
employment use or allocated to be
developed for employment um so that's
excluding the um prospective sites put
forward and call for sites we didn't you
know those are not in that figure so the
remainder of the sites were promoted
land that's still in the green Bel if
you refer to figure two in the reports
the uh pie chart there gives the um
breakdown of the existing sites um so
the sites already in employment use in
terms of total Site Area so 79% of those
in total are either established or newer
allocated sites whereas the other 21%
Falls within unallocated categories so
that's land which is in employment use
but not having a formal allocation
or land which was forly allocated as an
employment site but which was taken out
during the current core strategy so
sites like starlane industrial estate
and wakering for
example uh figure three U that gives a
breakdown of the site quality
assessment um 45% of these sites were
excellent or good um 41% were fair and
15% were poor um in general sites which
were allocated formerly tended to be of
better quality whilst those without
allocations were more likely to be poor
quality um the committee report provides
a series of findings and recommendations
by each site typology I won't go into
these in full this evening um as this is
a summary and but it is quite an
extensive one um it's also worth noting
the full report contains much more
detail on each of these um however there
are a few selected finding
recommendations from this section that I
would would pick out um so of the
established existing site allocations um
55% of these called fair or poor um
indicating that you know generally a lot
of site environments are are suboptimal
at the moment um efforts to address
these measures improve the over quality
of sites is imperative if they are to
remain attractive to the needs of new
and existing occupiers and there is a
risk that older poorer quality sites at
some point stop being you know viable
and you know you see more pressure for
development for alternative
uses um on existing sites around 12 to
13 hectares was found to be land which
was either vacant derel or
underutilized which could potentially be
brought into more effective employment
use um of the new allocated sites so the
ones that were allocated in the core
strategy um actually you know at time of
survey around 81% of these remained
undeveloped although sites like airport
Business Park and arterial Park were
progressing
um the um it's important that the
remainder of these sites is protected
for high quality employment use
particularly given the appeal decision
relating to the former Cherry Orchard
Brick Works which is seeing that um
which which went in favor of a developer
bringing that forward for a care
village um most of the unallocated sites
that were surveyed scored either fair or
poor in terms of site quality however
they were found to generally play an
important role in providing
accommodation for smaller micro
businesses rural businesses and
occupiers that are seeking more
affordable units so is you know they are
an important part of the overall of
employment ecosystem of the districts
and there are you know quite a number of
SES particularly in rural areas
fulfilling this role um most of these
sites most of those sites fall within
the green belt and are previously
developed land um there is potential for
them to play more of a role if certain
sites were either given an allocation or
some form of policy within the local PL
supported uh their protection and
limited improvements to such sites um
there have been a current and a couple
of recent approvals such as little
stbridge Hall and Celli Works um where
it has been demonstrated that there was
a strong need for the type of
accommodation being developed um because
there was a shortage of space for you
know particularly for small small
businesses you know who who who couldn't
you know who weren't able to access um s
uh units on existing you know
established
Estates um and in terms of the former
employment allocations um so those um
those three sites which were allocated
for residential and the current core
strategy these actually all remain well
occupied for employment purposes um so
it's important important to a knowledge
the role that these continue to play in
supporting businesses and we need to
carefully monitor the situation as to
any likely loss of these sites or any
likely loss of sites may require
alternative provision elsewhere to
offset the number of displaced
businesses and there are within the
committee report and wi report in the
appendix specific recommendations for
each of the
three um in terms of how I in terms of
looking at employment space need for the
local plan um so we refer back to the
Edna which um model four scenarios uh
the edner determines that the existing
supply of um employment allocations in
the current plan plus known planning
permissions is actually you know was
generally sufficient to meet projected
demand up to
2040 however it also acknowledge some
caveats with that and they need to do
further work uh on the one hand it
didn't account for you know expected
losses that you might see over the
planned period so typically you know
you're always going to see a number of
commercial buildings redeveloped for
other means
um you know you know where you know you
get an older industrial building which
you know is redeveloped for for housing
or something like that um this typ you
know typically a certain portion of
employment space is lost each year to
such uses um on the other hand it also
suggested um that there would be a need
to provide some additional high quality
floor space to meet you know particular
demands and um specialized business
accommodation which was deemed in short
supply um such as good quality flexible
workspace for small business businesses
or grow on space so for businesses that
are seeking to grow you know and move
from you know their existing startup
accommodation so those are those are
particular needs that have been
identified um it also should account for
any you know growth Ambitions to attract
new inward investment and it also
acknowledges that the edner modeling um
with uh the Cambridge econometrics model
used um doesn't model the property
requirements of certain industries which
includes construction Healthcare and
arts and entertainment
um in terms of identifying losses that
might be expected over the plan period
um good practice is to plan for the
first five years of plan period so
looking at we looked at the uh past
trends of employment space uh loss
between 202 20110 and
2022 um so if you if you you know to
allow for around five years of um sort
of unexpected losses that would probably
be 2.28 hectares which we might want to
replace in the new local plan and that
is shown in table two of the committee
report um the Ed also recommended
considering which sites might be
realistically lost to development in the
short to medium term IE within five
years uh sections 1.54 to 1.57 in the
item six report cover this including the
criteria of inclusion of sites in this
consideration um I should note that in
no ways a team suggesting that these
sites should be redeveloped for any
other use um but it's you know just good
practice the plan for contingencies in
case such sites are you know are
develops or you know there is pressure
for other uses and this um this exercise
identified 9.54 hectares of land
potentially at risk if you combine these
two figures um with the uh surpluses and
supply versus demand identified in the
Edna uh in the two more likely scenarios
we would suggest the new local plan
plans for approximately six to 10
hectares of new employment land um
probably more towards the upper end of
the spectrum if you if you want to
consider growth demand in sectors that
weren't included in the model like
construction and we do know that there
are you know fair and number of
construction occupiers on our employment
States um in terms of further sorry
further recommendations for emplo for
providing employment space um
accommodating some of this need could be
provided through maximizing uh vacant or
underutilized land on existing sites and
as I said the exercise did identify
possibly 12 to 13 hectares um or through
allocating some previously developed
sites you know um which which you know
pre previously developed land in the
green belt and allowing for their
modernization um it's also very
important to make the most of existing
Town centers and opportunities to
repurpose vacant space there and that
you know there are obviously um key
Brownfield regeneration opportunities
that could be taken up uh alongside this
there there may well be some need to
consider allocating new land for
employment uses um this could include
either Standalone site for employment
purposes such as some of the ones put
forward in the sites uh situated next to
existing employment areas or you could
consider allocation of some employment
space as part of um consideration of a
wider housing growth
location um and this would provide
sustainable well-located employment
provision close to New Homes this study
does not seek to suggest where such
sites combining housing employment
growth should go since this closely tied
to as an as yet undetermined spatial
strategy um new employment space ations
could also address Geographic
disparities in provision there are many
areas of the district which have little
to no formal employment space provision
as it is which include increases the
Reliance of residents or commuting other
parts of the district or Beyond um
particularly the case in terms of
settlements which had housing sites
allocated in the in the core strategy um
but there are no employment sites nearby
and probably the main example that the
study looked at here was uh was
holbridge
um other policy and final a few policy
recommendations
um
included the plan should provide a range
of sites including smaller sites um as
Reliance on a small number of employment
sites or or one or two developers you
might see the the floor space you that
does come through skewed towards you
know one particular type of unit so for
example certain developers like to build
you know very large distribution units
and then you haven't got any space for
smaller
businesses um you might want to adopt
policies which uh supp support or
require provision of particular types of
floor space um including smaller units
and flexible workspace suited to startup
businesses um could also include
considering whether existing employment
sites could benefit from greater
intensification or redevelop to
accommodate um these types of
uses um and we could look at policies
which seek to regularize some of the
existing lawful employment sites in
rural or green B locations to support
proportionate Improvement to the stock
there because obviously you know the um
the study highlighted that a lot of
these sites the building quality is
quite poor you could look to improve
some of that stock through you know
through through some sort of policy
inclusion and this would help rural
economy and small businesses seeking
affordable space in such areas um i'
like to thank you for listening which
was probably a fairly uh long
presentation uh this is just a summary
of what is quite a substantial report so
I'd be happy to take questions now or
come back to you after this committee
thanks thank you
chair any questions members on me
councelor
stept thank you um this document is
obviously a live
document uh and will be reviewed pretty
much on a constant basis how
frequently my first question is how
frequently will that be
reviewed
um I I mean you you're right that this
is a live document um the uh the policy
position you know for the new local plan
is is evolving so um you know this I
presumably would we would um you know we
would look at each stage of the local
plan to to determine whether you know
whether what's been said here is still
still relevant and whether we need um
some you know to to produce a you know
an update note on um on what's being
said and you know obviously we'll keep
the committee informed regularly okay um
the other couple of questions I've got
from May chairman um is around
employment land we touched on this prior
to the meeting uh and I I am surprised
that it isn't included uh although it is
of a very special nature and that is
Fess uh it's obviously very special
because it's owned by the Min Ministry
of Defense but it is um quite substant
quite substantial number of employees go
there both from the point of view of the
specialist jobs that are there and also
Coast the service industry that then
supports that um you know plumers the
carpers and have so I think that perhaps
somehow we do need to perhaps recognize
that within the document um and I think
that's
important uh the other item thing and it
may be a case we need to deal with it
after the meeting um there are a couple
of sites that I can think of that
haven't been included within this um
that are small small sites that perhaps
are you may want to consider taking
taking on board but I'm happy to do that
outside the
meeting thank you Mike
um sorry you come back oh sorry sorry
yeah um absolutely you know happy to
happy to discuss though you know
additional sites um and in terms of
fness the reason it wasn't included was
you know we we went by the um sort of
government planning policy well planning
practice guidance on employment land and
you know employment use classes which is
your typical
manufacturing distribution office and so
on but obviously we do acknowledge the
um you know the important role provided
by you know by the M mod land and you
know it it is its own special case but
does need acknowledging and and
obviously the local plan does need to
cater for for you know for that and
certainly in the last consultation stage
I recall but in future as well you know
we do um consult the um I think they
called the defense infrastructure
organization or you know the basic
essentially the government body that
manages the government Estates on um you
know on on the plan and and they did
respond Council Foster
please thank you chairman um couple of
sort of points and observations and a
question and a proposal um first of all
The Foundry Business Park figures on
quite a number of references it was
mentioned as being as at risk as a loss
the huley area action plan described it
as been reserved for uh business but I
know there's either a current uh
planning application or one imminent for
Housing Development on there so it
probably drops off I'm guessing
councilor Rees probably knows that very
well um the other thing is that
um um the Roth um industrial estate gets
mentioned a couple of
times um in Parts there's one reference
to plan to have been moved to melin's
farm um and other reports I've seen
there was supposed to be a
green uh separation between the park and
the housing there um it's a long and
complicated history and I I may me
suggest that
um perhaps a discussion outside of this
meeting maybe with particularly thean
Ward involved who's got a long history
might be helpful way of sort of getting
all that put together if that's
helpful uh I think I'll just make one
point instantly about The Foundry
Business Park um I should have mentioned
it says in the report it talks about the
two office blocks at the center one of
them being in a state of Abandonment and
disrepair it's never been completed the
owner of the site planned to put a
restaurant in downstairs in that for his
son I think it was and they fell out and
it never got finished because it would
have attracted business rates if it was
completed and they didn't have any to
occupy it so it's it it's not abandoned
but it's not being
completed thank you councilor Foster um
happy to happy to amend the report to
you know to reflect that and um I think
since the site visit was undertaken I
did learn more about the site history um
so yeah we can we can we can go back and
change
that and um happy also to have sorry if
I made CH just is everybody happy with
that idea of a of a working group get
together on industrial estate yeah got
suggest
[Music]
okay Council ho
please sorry I was going to follow on
from Council Foster um there's a general
point and also a specific point in
relation the the specific point is
Around The Foundry which is the hoper
area action plan which has been in
existence for a number of years now and
is still valid
which and and it is designated as
employment land essentially um the
report is essentially saying
that we to me it seems like the report
is saying that if a planning application
comes forward for residential we'd find
it very hard to to deal with because of
the night the nature of the site
essentially the the poor repair of the
the um workshops and offices Etc
um that's the first point to hold the
second point is a bit Fuller than that
in that we've also lost other employment
land with the the Jack one I think it
was the additional sites um to his um
sheltered housing essentially I think um
and that sort of thing and I'm just
wondering what weight we can give to our
policies if they seem to be overridden
like that I mean I I think they there
were the fs with the hotar area action
plan but I think they were probably
right about Elden way and and The
Foundry about their uses but I find it
it seems to me on this report what's
actually happening outside of this
committee that we're finding those hard
to defend so I don't know if these are
just a
extreme examples of where we wouldn't be
able to defend or or if they just
generally we unable to
defend um thank you thank you chair
thank you thank you councelor Hoy um
those those are both valid points um and
actually you know I've been involved in
providing comments you know on behalf of
the economic development team on on both
The Foundry and on the Cherry Ultra
brick work site and um you know we we we
did seek to you know protect and defend
those and you know certainly we
certainly on Foundry you know there is
you know we you know we would want a
very high bar of evidence demonstrate
from the developer as to why that site
is not viable as to why they you know
they they they cannot um you know well
they can't you know they can't find
additional occupies and so on um yeah we
certainly certainly um you know I've
been you know I've written some quite
robust comments on that um also you know
gave evidence to the U to the inquire
with regards to Cherry Ultra brick works
unfortunately I I would just say you
know the there is there is um you know
it is it is quite a challenge to um you
know to defend some of these sites and
um we we do our
best okay thank you so essentially that
they are they should be in here as they
are hoty re area action plan is still
valid it's it's still valid and um sorry
s um it is still valid um and and
certainly yeah I've I've issued you know
some some quite strong critiques as to
you know what the the applicant has
submitted um they are supposedly coming
back with with more evidence I I believe
um obviously it's development Control
process and you know that that has to
follow process but certainly we you know
we are seeking to defend that and also
you know working closely with economic
development colleagues because we
understand that a number of the um the
tenants there have already you know sort
of been asked to move on or and some
others are concerned about you know
where they might go in future so we need
to you know also fully explore that and
you know we we we want to ensure that
actually you know well well on one hand
we we need to ensure that there are well
we need to work out are there any
alternatives that these businesses can
go to because if there aren't then well
that's that's a serious material
consideration and you know that ought to
be reflected in you know in in the
planning application um the two office
blocks that are part of Foundry are I
think they were both subject to um
permitted development applications um it
um but it's subsequently and obviously
you know in recent years government
legislation has made it easier to you
know to change vacant commercial
properties to residential however one of
them for the time being I believe I
think because of potential imity issues
for future residents because of
proximity to the train line for noise
and that that that is not suitable for
that route and the other one because as
was pointed out earlier that that
building was never actually completed um
it doesn't qualify for the um the
permitted development route which the
developer sought to take it down and and
you know I did have a conversation with
the um the planning officer in question
about that so we we're keeping a really
close eye on this and
um I certainly issuing you know probably
more coherent responses um when typing
down then then when responding to now
verbally rest assured no it's great
thank you for that sorry chairman I've
just realized in the 323 Pages just
lighted on the name of um Dolan's Farm I
I um rent an office from Dolan's Farm in
in radi so I think I better declare that
as a a non-pecuniary
interest thanks
Mike Council
Reeves thank you chair um to put a
little bit of context on the Elder the
The Foundry industrial estate uh issue
there there have been many many
conversations with the developer members
and officers on that I know that the uh
as um Dan has actually suggested there
has been some quite robust conversations
there the particular application that
has come onto the um uh weekly list uh
this week
um that one has been asking for a a
quite detailed um sound um report uh
exactly as you said but one of the
things that I think has been useful
about it actually being a uh designated
as a an industrial area is that they
have had to incorporate commercial and
Industrial facility within it I think
without the uh a area action plan they
could have very easily under current
legislation got away with taking the
whole thing down and uh replacing it
with um uh Flats the
um the other issue that uh I I quite
Keen to see a little bit more robust in
the uh in the report um you talked about
uh ensuring that we have small
units um in the M manufacturing industry
if we are going to be a district that is
going to be encouraging growth growth
has to start from somewhere if we you
look at historically the amount of uh
developments that have been put forward
in recent times for industrial premises
they've all been fairly big there's
nothing really around about thousand
square foot sort of uh size which is the
kind of size where you would get someone
who is looking to start a business in a
manufacturing element that is the kind
of size that they would be looking to be
look looking for to be affordable to
actually make sure that they have the
best chance of starting off their
business obviously they would be looking
to hopefully move to bigger premises but
without that startup size we are very
limited I'd like to see a little bit
more strength in the report actually
pushing for um in some proportion the
smaller elements of industrial units so
as we do actually do what we say on on
on the Ken in encouraging uh businesses
to uh start grow and become uh into
their potential thank
you
thank you Council EES um yeah um on and
on the um on the first point your you're
right that you know it's good that we
have the action plan in place um and as
a result the developer has actually put
forward some employment space obviously
they're Keen to suggest it's a kind of
like for like but you know we know that
there are existing occupiers there you
know some think there's a couple of
garages Foundry tires who you know who
who obviously aren't going to be a an
ideal candidate for what the developers
want to build there so we you know
whatever happens we need to consider the
interests of those occupiers because
they're long-standing businesses um on
the second Point um about small units
and as you said um you know starting
around a th square foot um that is yeah
that's that's a point that I think um
both myself and my colleagues in the
economic development been um keen on for
quite some time so there's um there's a
document called the south6 grow on Space
study 2020 which is the main piece of
evidence that we refer back to on this
um so that talks about how as you say
you know especially institutional
investors and you know large developers
allocated sites they they like to build
very large floor plate um units
obviously you know you get a much better
return on investment for that and you
know what we're seeing at arterial Park
um some of those units are very large
some are a bit on the smaller side um
but typically you know if you look
around the country and certainly South
essics and the a127 corridor you know
you do see those very large units um you
know and there is a preference there you
know we spoken to the to agents in the
past and and that's definitely seems to
be something which you know which is a
preference and and we'll have to see
what comes back um I've been promised at
the end of this week by the uh the um
the Consultants that we'll get the
commercial property market review back
which involves engaging with the
property Community to you know to
understand what drives them and you know
what they see being you know in demand
at the moment um but yeah we're very
mindful of the need to develop um those
those those smaller industrial units uh
and you know certainly you only have to
do a right move search of commercial
property in the district to see that
actually there's not a great deal of you
know sort of small workshops warehouses
what there is is often not of great
quality this is why you know we are
seeing you know a lot of at the smaller
end a lot of businesses kind of setting
up on you know farms and in former
agricultural buildings because there is
little alternative um and where you know
where developers have sought to develop
sort of newer um property at the smaller
ends for example on the airport Business
Park they developed um 12 units called
the quads there uh so those are smaller
units I think they
go I think the largest is probably about
6,000 square foot and the smallest is
probably one to one and a half thousand
square foot and those all let very well
and and actually that you know we we'
we've spoken with with Henry boot about
that and whether there'll be potential
to see more of that on that site because
you know they are very key again to you
know to focus on the larger units but
actually there is a role for you know
for those smaller businesses too and
those are those are the kind of
businesses in the south in the Rockford
area who you know who want to grow who
want to invest and and need the premises
to do it so yeah um we've got some
evidence that informs it and we would
definitely look to you know to to
develop our policies and the plan to see
more of those type of units going coming
forward councilor H yeah sorry CH just
very quickly following on from Council
Rees um I think it's paragraph 5.87
which talks about
um one option that could be considered
is to allocate land for employment
purposes within or adjacent to housing
growth areas but it's a bit it goes on
say could be a bit speculative at the
moment but it does it is recommended
that the potential for employment land
delivery alongside new housing is
explored further as a plan progresses um
it's recommended but it's not it's just
in that paragraph that I can tell is
that something we can particularly
highlight so that we don't lose track of
that when we are doing that because I
think it I I'm an account I deal with
local business as well Adrian sorry
councel Rees he's absolutely right about
the size and and nature of some of the
the units that are available at the
moment and there's a real demand for it
and I think our um as part of my
Economic Development role there's
there's
clearly a demand for these I mean we've
now got the launch pad at the um Cherry
Ard way which is a private operator I
know but it it's more things like that
and more indust small industrial units
certainly a need I definitely think we
need to keep that in focus when we're
developing the plan
further thank you chair um thank you
counc Hoy um yes very happy to draw that
out more and put more emphasis on on
exploring that because it is important
and you know obviously it's it's good
planning to to bring forward employment
alongside housing because you know if if
people can work close to where they live
then you know it reduces the need to
travel generally which which has to be a
good thing for infrastructure in the
area and um and sorry councelor e just
to go back on your point yes I'll also
you know draw out the emphasis on um you
know those those industrial units in the
report as
well any more questions
members me Council step
time chairman thank you picking up on
the points of councelor e and councelor
Hoy there um I think perhaps we I ought
to like to propose that we actually add
that to the recommendation that the
document reflects what has been
discussed here and I'd also like to add
that it gives special acknowledgement to
fess and the situation
there you're happy to confirm that happy
to um on on fness I I think it might
need a bit more of um a conversation and
perhaps a specific policy approach but
certainly happy to to reference it in
the document and it's
important
that as a proposition okay
well any further questions on that one
okay there's a recommendation set out
and it reads that the planning policy
committee notes the report as part of
the evidence base for the emerging local
plan and I now need to find some words
to catch mik's sorry so thanks chairman
you said you're going to come back on
the lth industry Park I some chair
notes okay thank
you so I need some words to a one liner
there to add to that I guess to kth and
Mike's request that what we've discussed
on this particular
document Dan's obviously committed to
update the document uh anyway um
so what I should suggest is we add to
that
[Music]
wording something noise and simple
including subjects
discussed at the
meeting is that easy enough does that
cover
it so we'll add that on the end of we
may
Veronica can I note it in that
form yeah happy with that y
[Music]
okay yeah um before I close down um
couple of points for
myself um we have to book meetings at
long range now because there's quite a
demand for meeting the meetings and the
Council of Staff who have to support
them so don't for your diary the next
formal uh planning policy meeting will
be the 7th of
March in the
meantime uh February we'll see a
Workshop
meeting because we need to catch up on
some various items and what I like to
suggest Ian is that that item could be
covered there in that format if you
would perhaps give me a brief synopsis
of what you got in mind say by the end
of
January and then
we
sorry
remind me of the date of the workshop
it' be in February I haven't put a date
on it we've got a book somewhere but uh
if you could just give me a synopsis by
the end of the month on what you want to
cover and then then we can manage the
meeting and make sure we cover all the
other aspects that we've got some
documents we'd like to familiarize you
with so that when they come to the 7th
of March formal meeting you'll be aware
of them in the BS and had a chance to
think about them can I assume that's our
uh 7:30 meeting in 7th of
March
thank
you put my mic on oh then got through to
without forgetting um I just like to say
thanks to Daniel
for helping uh Jonathan get up to speed
bearing in mind Jonathan's had about
seven days in the job um and this is a
mountain of stuff to absorb he did
overlap with Dan good good Goodman
before went in order to get some of that
and Dan I know helped as well but Dan's
putting a bit of leg work and so thanks
to Dan and thanks to Jonathan for
picking it picking it up for us um next
time hopefully
Lee uh will be here the new the interim
director of place a
full-time replacement director of place
will come to be at the end of the first
quarter she the lady has been
chosen he's serving three months notice
not in prison three months notice um so
we have to wait for her but fair play to
Lee he stepped up to stand in and fill
the gap for that time during that period
so if I get a chance to introduce him to
you in some other way I will
do I'll make it
8:32 and formally close the meeting in
by